hello everyone and welcome to round five
over the 2019 Tata Steel chess
tournament
we haven't been covering every round as
I didn't really feel like the games that
were played were really that interesting
to show there were a couple of them but
I was rather busy and we're also
covering the Capablanca saga so I hope
you don't mind but we are going to cover
two games from round five and do I have
a question for you now do you remember
when was the last time Magnus Carlsen
won a game in classical time format you
should know since we covered that game
on this channel so feel free to pause
the video and really think about your
answer for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent subscriber and for those of
you who answered he won a game against
Nakamura in the sinful Cup in 2018 you
almost got it right he did win that game
but she also won one game after that
it's his game against Potkin in the
European Club Cup we also covered that
game and after that game cousin drew
four of his games in the European Club
Cup then he drew 12 classical games
against Fabiano Khurana and watch a
championship match at 16 and here he
drew his first four games in the tata
steel chess term in 2019 so that's 20
games drawn in a row which is a lot for
any player let alone the world champion
so here he faces jordan van forest who
played last year in the tata steel
challengers tournament for those of you
who are new to chess may be new to hold
this whole tournaments thing going on
the tata steel chess tournament
comprises of the Masters Tournament and
the challengers tournament the last
year's winner of the challengers
tournament was with its hunter so he
Gujarati so he's now of course playing
in the Masters Tournament and I believe
Forrest finished in fifth place so I
guess he's maybe got an invitation to
this year's masters or perhaps he's a
wild card it's hard to say if any of you
do know the exact information do share I
will also add it in the description or
open your comment or whatnot but yeah it
was an October 13th
last year that's called someone his last
classical game so without further ado
let's check out this game it's a very
nice game features a line that was
played in in the match callsign versus
Caruana I don't know if you've been
following that match if you haven't do
check it out it's a really really in an
intense match but I will we're just
gonna stroll through the opening as
we've covered that in pretty much every
game over the course and Caruana match
since Carson played it with the black
pieces in every game night of three let
me just fix that nice the c6 we have
before so this is the Sicilian defense
is on the board
C captures Knight captures in the knight
to f6 we have Knight to c3 and now in
five we have the Alaska a variational or
the Pelican variation of the Sicilian
Knight db5 everything the same as in
Caruana versus Colson d6 and now comes
Knights to d5 everyone was surprised
when they saw that Jordan went for this
variation very brave of him as of course
Carson is really into opening theory
unlike capablanca especially about this
line he had to of course prepare it for
for carvanha and it's I don't know of
course Carson knows this better but then
again maybe he didn't look at it after
the vulture Championship match so maybe
Jordan prepared something very nice for
him but on the other hand maybe he
thought it'd be a good psychological
weapon against cousin as he failed to
win a single game using this line in the
World Chess Championship match so either
way a very interesting approach
we have Knight captures he captures and
now if you remember in two of the games
in the World Chess Championship match
cousin retreated with Knights b8 in the
other two games he played nicely 7 but
this game the game two of them are
playing will be following a move by move
Game two of the rapid section where
Carson was able to win with the black
pieces Albert okay Knight g6
we have Queen to a4 now threatening
discoveries Bishop to d7 this was all
played in Causton versus Caruana
Queen before getting out of the pin and
now Queen to b8
everything exactly the same here George
Enescu wanna play the h4 Crossan plays
h5 Bishop to e3
here we have a six-night goes back to c3
and in this position cousin played a 5
here attacking occur honest Queen and
cousin was able to win that game with
the black pieces but as everyone knows
these games they are probably the most
famous games played in 2018 of course
the Jordan forest knows them as well so
Carlsen here doesn't go for this it
seems that cousin analyzed his own games
as well as pie even the rapid ones and
he plays f5 and this is indeed the
better choice the engine prefer the
prefers this move this one that he
played against Caruana
and as of this moment we have a
completely new game that was never
played before it's a I don't have the
exact same time Jordan used in this
position to make his next move but I do
have the final times on the clock if
anyone knows how much time Jordan spent
on this move exactly do sure it I will
also either in you know give it a heart
or something so everyone else can also
enjoy this information but ok here we
have queenside castle but shortly 7
crafts and is preparing to Castle
kingside
we have G 3 and the now count
strengthened in the h4 pawn and now
comes castles and also preventing f4
Bishop to e2 attacking the h5 pawn and
here cross and goes for efore he
sacrifices the h5 pawn at make his
attack happen just a little bit faster
and here indeed if we capture in 95
Knights d3 is a threat you have to go
back with the Bishop then comes b5 and
already the cross and is starting
another strong attack on the Queen side
characters captures a3 and you still
have to activate your Bishop repair but
after something like rush of BH to a5
maybe this Bishop can go here maybe to
g6 it will be it will be a very strong
attack for black so after E 4 and we
have Bishop to d4
doesn't Jordan doesn't bother himself
with the h5 pawn but rather he prevents
nice to e5 he prevents it with a nifty
trick of course if this then Bishop
captures pawn captures Queen captures
any seven wins upon a Windsor bishop
so after Bishop before crossing was
Bishop f6 he wants the trade bishops and
then go 95 Bishop captures we have rook
captures on f6 and now Queen to b6 and
okay Knight to e5 we have King Tubby one
getting his King to safety and now comes
Bishop - eh now the bishop can either or
control the Queen side or it can go to
g6 but also it frees the d7 square for
Carlson's night to pick away the Queen
after the queen is kicked away then
Carlsen can start activating his Queen
his rook and so on we have work to do -
and now comes Knight d7 as planned
24 and Queen to c7 the Queen is now also
activated and now call since other
inactive rook can come into play Knights
the d1 maneuvering to e3
we have Knight to e5 and now comes
Knight to e3 and here the knight is a
nicely placed but also it's not really
doing all that much
it's pressuring f5 it can never come to
g4 it
okay gives further protection to the c4
pawn but it can never go to see for
himself so it's a hard hard to say
Carson doesn't waste any more time he
decides to open lines he plays f4
attacks the night ended the g3 pawn G
captures rook captures and now comes
rock to g1 and here you can already see
that the semi open G file is very useful
for white there's no immediate danger
like if you move the night you're
getting checkmated as the Queen from c7
is also controlling the g7 square but
you know the pressure is there Bishop to
g6 by crossing aligning this bishop with
the King very useful also it for the
moment it blocks the rooks attack
towards the g7 point King to a-1 getting
out of this nasty diagonal and now comes
look a to f8 finally activating the
other rook doubling up on the F file and
here you have to decide what kind of a
player do you want to be do you wanna
defend the f2 pawn and stay passive for
the rest of the game let's say 91
defense the F to pawn the Queen is now
also defending it
but now the Queen and Knight are pretty
much
defending that pawn it's a it's a very
hard position to play you can either
capture on h4 you can play Knight f3
you can go b5 a lot of options for black
and black will be better in every
situation here
so Jordan decides to not not to go for
this passive defense but rather for an
active last you know last call he plays
a c5 and c5 is a very nice idea it comes
out with the idea that if these chapters
on c5 then Queen moves preparing it to
push the past pawn via d6 and after the
Queen blocks now Bishop captures on h5
this was his idea after Bishop captures
now you get night c4 attacking the Queen
but also comes with a double attack
against the knight on e5 and now you
cannot capture the Queen left the c7
square it will be Queen captures on g7
checkmate so you would have to just move
the Queen a let's say Queen f6 and then
comes Knight captures and then white you
know white is still playing this game
black is better but White has a passed
pawn equalized in material it's you know
it's possible but after c5 cousin you
know he didn't become world champion by
missing ideas like these he plays rook
captures on f2 just grabbing a pawn you
know increasing the activity of his
rooks we have Queen to c3 and now not D
captures on c5 if you play this then d6
you're no longer defending the knight
now after you move it's white who's
actually winning
so across and simply plays Queen
captures on c5 he's up material he has
no problems trading Queens and it's very
hard to define this Queen trade if you
play something like 91 to either trade
Queens here it doesn't really help you
you can simply play Queen captures
Knight captures and then Knight to f3
where you can either grab the night with
the both of your ropes are under attack
you can either capture here and then
rope captures or you can capture on g6
and then Knight capture some d2 wins the
exchange either way you make some room
for your king you force the rogue back
and then you know black is still better
up the exchange has more pawns a
completely winning position for black so
after Queen captures on c5 which was
played in the game we have D captures
and now comes
these six have enforced tries to push
his passport and now going night of
three immediately seems like a great
idea you know working the looks and
everything but here it would actually
allow white some saving chances after
Bishop to c4 check you open up an attack
against you lookin after which is
undefended and after Bishop here rook
captures you would be a special
characters and see for now
rook to see one attacking the bishop and
after Bishop moves of course it will be
black was still even being done in
exchange will be better as he does have
a passed pawn here but you know white
will definitely be able to save this
game so after d6 first cousin please
King to h7 he doesn't allow this checked
even remain a possibility we have d7 by
Jordan and now comes Knight to f3 this
was the last move it was in this
position that Jordan when forest
resigned the game and it hasn't been a
great tournament for him so far he
before facing Carlsen he was one out of
four I believe he's not one out of five
so I don't think he won a game I think
he got two draws and lost all the other
games but still playing such a such an
impressive game against the cost and in
choosing the line that he knew that
Carson was I mean absolutely prepared
for he used it in the World Championship
match it's very very brave and you know
he really wanted to play good chess you
don't get you it's not every day you get
a chance to face the world champion so
you know it better better make it count
but yeah again it's there's really
nothing to do here after Bishop captures
you'll play route capture some D to
guard the b7 pawn and after rook to d1
offering to trade you can simply trade
down the bunch of characters and now I
have to rook to b8 it's row captures
your ear of the exchange Europe Europe
three points are completely winning
position and of course Georgian does not
want to test the course and skill in
converting this into a win sir that's a
game from around five of the 2019
toughest Oh chess tournament I do hope
you enjoyed it and congratulations to
everyone who guessed when Carlson's last
win in
classical time form it was but now the
curse is broken and this now becomes
here's the last game that he won in the
in classical time format we're also
going to cover one other game it's same
Shanklin versus ding Liron excellent
game but every game by ding leerin is an
excellent game even his drawers are
excellent you know that that guy is is
unable to play in a game that's not
excellent but yeah
ok that's the game hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Scott's theory I
recalled Paul staples Wayne Wylie and
Ross Glenny for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
like we said the game same Shanklin V vs
ding Lehrer and then as soon as I manage
we're continuing the Capablanca saga and
1911's on Sebastiaan tournament thank
you all and I'll see you soon